Speaker 1: The latest bogus COVID treatment slash
prophylactic slash cure. It's all of the above. In
reality, it's none is inhaling hydrogen peroxide
through an asthma nebulizer. Now I'm going to say
it a number of times throughout this segment
to remain in compliance. This is a bad idea,
not evidence based, not recommended by
actual doctors, and can be very harmful
to your health. So don't nebulizer. Hydrogen
peroxide through asthma inhalers, I'm merely
telling you that there are people doing it. Last
week, we talked about so-called urine therapy,
which involves drinking urine, rubbing it on
your skin, using it in a neti pot. You know,
it does not do anything for COVID, despite what
that crazy guy told you about last week says
the new one is inhaling aerosolized. I guess we
would call it hydrogen peroxide. This is wildly
spreading, and it's crazy because we had this long
weekend. I check back in on the news when we get
back from the long weekend and all of a sudden
hydrogen peroxide inhalation is everywhere. So
here's one guy explaining how the hydrogen
peroxide protects him not only from COVID,
but from people shedding vaccine on him, which
is a whole other insane, widely debunked thing.
And again, as a pre disclaimer. Essentially,
nothing that you're going to hear in this clip is
accurate. So let's take a listen in, as
Speaker 2: there's been a lot of articles
saying, Oh, this is terrible for you. Don't
ever do this. Don't ever inhale nebulizer
hydro peroxide, but hydrogen peroxide. If a doctor
is going to go on and actually say to do this,
you know, I trust in one doctor again.
I forget his name, but I'll post it.
Speaker 1: There's one doctor who is saying
to do this, and the guy doesn't remember
that doctor's name, but all the other ones
are saying don't. He trusts the one doctor
whose name he doesn't remember.
Speaker 2: He knows more. Cola
has a conversation with him in a rumble.
Speaker 1: And by the way, any time you hear
the name Dr. Mercola, head for the hills, folks.
Speaker 2: They're also on bed shoot where they
talk about the guy's been bitch shoot.
Speaker 1: What on earth is happening
Speaker 2: doing this since
the 90s? Now he also utilizes
iodine and puts like a draw by the iodine.
Speaker 1: Thing also was floating around a
few months ago. That's totally debunked as well
Speaker 2: going into the into the medicine
bottle here. I haven't tried that yet. I'm going
to try it. I'm actually got someone ordering see
the iodine that they're recommending, I think
is it costs like nine bucks for two little.
Speaker 1: Doesn't this guy just inspire
confidence in terms of medical treatments
Speaker 2: or something like that? So
again, there are different ways to do it,
but I find that this is the easiest
way. Plus you got it like, you know,
in the fridge and it's ready to go.
So whenever I go to a rally or I'm
going to a restaurant or I went to the
movies of the night and stuff like that,
and you know, I don't ever wear a mask, so right?
Not that they help. But I the first thing I do
is I come in and I put one of these on.
Speaker 1: Isn't that brilliant? He says,
I do this because I don't ever wear a mask,
even though the masks don't help. Well,
then why do you need to do something in lieu
of wearing a mask like you could analyze
every sentence and it wouldn't make any sense?
Speaker 2: Also, I don't have to wait for that,
to be honest with you. When I get up in the
morning, I do this. And since then, I haven't been
taking any antihistamines, anything like that. I
haven't been taking any cold medication. I haven't
had any light congestion. My sleep has been a
lot better and I and I attribute it to this now.
Speaker 1: I want to point something
out as a veteran, he says. This is the
Speaker 2: only thing that I've done this.
Speaker 1: He attributes it to this.
Any time this, this starts, this is a very common
thing in general in the kind of quack cures thing,
which is they start to tell you, it
basically cures and treats everything
you know. And this has been floating around
for a long time and it's everything from,
you know, you can find that drinking colloidal
silver, it's basically it treats everything or
pomegranate or any time something treats
so many conditions and deals with so many
symptoms. Aside from the fact that this is not a
medical professional, we should all be skeptical
Speaker 2: and really different. So nebulizer,
Speaker 1: unless it's like, you know,
maintaining a regimen of a good diet exercise
going outside every single day, it's like, yes,
that all together, that entire lifestyle
is good for a lot of different things.
But whenever it's like hydrogen peroxide treats
all these things, we should be very skeptical.
Speaker 2: 80 bucks, 90 with tax, I would say
eight to ten dollars for for the food grade,
12 percent hydrogen peroxide for 100
bucks. I think it's worth it. And again,
like I said, I I went to the movies the
other night in Pasadena. You don't have to
show a vax card and we didn't wear a mask and
we're in the, you know, in there with a bunch of,
you know, backstopped people shedding all over
us and everything like that, even though they got
mask on. I put, you know, the first thing I did
this was I got home as I had. This takes about
10 minutes to go to the end here and you can watch
TV while you're doing it. It's not that obtrusive,
Speaker 1: so he's using it interesting to protect
himself not only from the virus, but also from
vaccine shedding, which again, we've debunked all
of this. So do not inhale hydrogen peroxide, OK?
Healthline has published extensively on this. It
can hurt your lungs. It won't prevent COVID. There
is a quote from. The AMFA, which is the Asthma and
Allergy Foundation of America, they said hydrogen
peroxide can be used as a cleaner and stain
remover and can cause tissue damage if you swallow
it or breathe it in. Dr. Len Horovitz, who's a
nationally recognized pulmonary specialist, said
that this could seriously harm people. Quote the
very beginning of this let's talk about things
that are ridiculous. Way back in March of 2020, I
had a patient send me something from what seemed
to be a scientific study that explained the virus
is inactivated by heat and suggested putting a
hairdryer up to your nose five minutes every day.
Maybe they were just trying to sell hair dryers.
Don't do this, guys. It's extraordinarily
dangerous. It's a very, very bad idea.
And what's endlessly fascinating as a as a sort
of detached observer is they seem determined
to try anything other than the vaccine,
which we know is very likely to keep you
out of serious COVID. Anything else,
they'll try iodine hairdryer up your nose,
nebulizer, hydrogen peroxide, urine
therapy. But we've got the vaccine.
It's FDA approved. It works really well at
preventing serious illness and yet that they
don't seem to want. It's truly incredible. It's
like they're determined to thin themselves out,
either by getting COVID and dying or by using
dangerous so-called treatments which are not
actually treatments. And again, just as a
reminder, this is an unproven treatment that
shouldn't be called a treatment that can hurt
you. So do not nebulizer hydrogen peroxide.